j'ai fait plus autant le fier là
[Musique]
et aux chochottes qui cette fois un
manoir on doit le tenir jusqu'à ce que
la relève arrive imaginez vous un peu ce
bonheur
c'était un endroit important quand les
parades la 82e sont venus déloger les
nazis puis retournez aux voiliers
attentes de les voir se pointer restera
plus qu'à s'occuper d'eux
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça un carnet qui était dans
la cave il appartenait à un des nazis
qui ont tenu la place il parle de la
famille qui vivait là et de ce qu'ils
leur ont fait
je reste là dedans sera piégé comme des
rats et vous êtes tous prêt à finir en
prison militaire on peut pas s'en aller
là y'a un truc pas naturel sans voix est
mille fois pire que
c'était quoi ça
je vais dire ce à quoi on pense tous
cette maison est hantée si tu laisses le
malade venir il reviendra tout pour
monter au centuple
rassembler le matériel et préparez vous
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on a vu depuis qu'on est là
c'est ce que les nazis au fait subir à
la famille qui vivait ici
on peut pas s'en aller ils veulent pas
nous laisser partir
c'est pareil c'est pas réel
c'est parée aile séparée elle s'est
préparée